Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The coach left from Chorlton Street, Manchester, just after 11 on Sunday evening, picking up speed as it reached the M62. It was packed with servicemen and their families, young men telling jokes under their breath, young wives trying to get some sleep, children snoring or staring out of the window, who had spent the weekend with friends and relatives in Manchester and were now heading back to their barracks in Catterick and Darlington. Normally, they would have taken the train, but of course there were no trains because of the
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。周日晚上11点刚过，长途客车从曼彻斯特的乔尔顿街出发，驶上M62公路后开始加速。车上挤满了军人及其家属，年轻人在低声讲着笑话，年轻的妻子们试图补觉，孩子们有的在打呼噜，有的望着窗外发呆。他们刚在曼彻斯特与亲友度过周末，现在正赶回卡特里克和达灵顿的军营。通常他们会选择坐火车，但由于
strike that had crippled the railway network since December. So the army had booked a North Yorkshire coach company to pick them up. As it happened, the driver, Roland Hanley, was a director of the firm and knew the route well. By midnight, he had almost reached Leeds, making excellent time along the motorway, and behind him many of the passengers were fast asleep. And then it happened. One moment, the coach was cruising smoothly and effortlessly through the night. The next, there was an almighty, heart-stopping bang. So Dominic, that's from your book, State of Emergency, The Way We Were, Britain, 1970 to 1974. And tell us what's happened.
自去年12月以来瘫痪了铁路网络的罢工，当然没有火车可坐。于是军方预订了一家北约克郡客运公司的车来接他们。巧合的是，司机罗兰·汉利（Roland Hanley）是该公司的董事，对路线非常熟悉。午夜时分，他沿着高速公路行驶，时间把握得非常好，几乎已经到达利兹，车后座的许多乘客都已熟睡。就在这时，意外发生了。前一刻，客车还在夜色中平稳、轻松地行驶。下一刻，一声震耳欲聋、令人心惊胆战的巨响传来。多米尼克，这段内容出自你的书《紧急状态：我们曾经的样子，英国，1970年至1974年》。告诉我们发生了什么。
So the date is the 4th of February, 1974. And this is one of the most devastating attacks launched by the IRA, the Irish Republican Army, on British soil. So what has just happened to that coach, packed with servicemen and their families, is that 25 pounds of high explosive have gone off in one of the luggage lockers. The whole rear of the coach was torn apart. Roland Hanley, from the reading, was one of the directors of the coach company. He somehow managed to, God knows how, to steer the rest of the coach towards the side of the road. He had been in the RAF in Cyprus, so he'd seen stuff, but nothing could have prepared him for what he saw when he got out. Because he gets out and he sees that the whole of the back of the coach is kind of blackened wreckage. It has literally been shredded by the
日期是1974年2月4日。这是爱尔兰共和军（IRA）在英国本土发动的最具破坏性的袭击之一。那辆挤满军人及其家属的客车刚刚遭遇了袭击，25磅的高爆炸药在行李舱中引爆。客车的整个后部被炸得粉碎。书中提到的罗兰·汉利是客运公司的董事之一。天知道他是怎么做到的，他竟然设法将剩下的车身驶向路边。他曾在塞浦路斯的英国皇家空军服役，所以见过大场面，但当他下车时，眼前的一切让他毫无心理准备。因为他下车后看到，客车的整个后部变成了一片焦黑的残骸。它简直被
bomb. There are bodies all over the motorway. There are people staggering off the coach covered in blood. In all, 12 people were killed that night, 11 of them immediately and one later. 50 were injured. A whole family was killed. The Houghton family, Corporal Clifford Houghton, he was 23. People got married much younger in the 70s than they do today. So he was 23 and he had two children, a five-year-old and a two-year-old, and is this terrible sore, I guess, of the violence in the political conflict in Northern Ireland, which as we said last time,
炸弹撕成了碎片。高速公路上到处都是尸体。有人浑身是血地从车里踉跄着走出来。那晚总共有12人丧生，11人当场死亡，1人后来不治身亡。50人受伤。一整个家庭遇难了。霍顿（Houghton）一家，克利福德·霍顿（Clifford Houghton）下士，他才23岁。70年代的人结婚比现在早得多。所以他才23岁，就有两个孩子，一个五岁，一个两岁。我想，这就是北爱尔兰政治冲突中暴力带来的可怕创伤，正如我们上次所说，
it kicked off in the late 1960s. It's absolutely worthy of Arrested History series on itself. But what has happened is that after years of terrible violence in Belfast in particular, the provisional IRA have decided to bring their campaign to what they see as the heart of the enemy, to Britain itself. And so from March 1973, they've been detonating bombs at various points, particularly in London or in Birmingham. This is one of the worst so far. And their strategy for doing this is basically because even though people are dying in huge numbers in Belfast and Northern Ireland, most people in Britain, they're aware of it, of course, as background noise.
它始于20世纪60年代末。这绝对值得专门制作一个《历史的余味》系列来讲述。但发生的情况是，在贝尔法斯特经历了多年的可怕暴力事件后，临时派爱尔兰共和军决定将他们的行动带到他们眼中的敌人心脏地带，即英国本土。因此，从1973年3月开始，他们一直在各地引爆炸弹，特别是在伦敦或伯明翰。这是迄今为止最严重的一次袭击。他们采取这种策略的原因基本上是，尽管贝尔法斯特和北爱尔兰有大量人员伤亡，但大多数英国人对此虽然有所耳闻，但将其视为背景噪音。
But they just wish it would go away. Absolutely. And so the aim is partly to force the government to negotiate and hopefully withdraw from the IRA's point of view. But also just to kind of rouse public opinion in Britain against Northern Ireland remaining in the United Kingdom. Exactly. It's almost, I suppose, to sort of bludgeon British public opinion into pressing for British withdrawal. Yes. I mean, some of our listeners from Ireland or Northern Ireland may be surprised to hear you say that it's background noise, but all the opinion polls, all the survey evidence shows that
但他们只是希望这一切能消失。没错。所以，其目的部分是为了迫使政府进行谈判，并希望从爱尔兰共和军的角度来看，实现撤军。但同时也为了激起英国公众对北爱尔兰留在联合王国内部的反对情绪。没错。我想，这几乎是为了用重锤敲打英国公众舆论，迫使其要求英国撤军。是的。我的意思是，我们的一些爱尔兰或北爱尔兰听众可能会对你说这是“背景噪音”感到惊讶，但所有的民意调查和调查证据都显示，
actually most people in England, Scotland and Wales, they'd never crossed the Irish Sea. They'd never been to Northern Ireland. They didn't understand it. And frankly, terrible thing to say in some ways, they didn't care. Yeah. They found it confusing and they were depressed by the news, but they didn't really understand it and they didn't devote an enormous amount of thought to it.
实际上，大多数英格兰、苏格兰和威尔士人从未跨越过爱尔兰海。他们从未去过北爱尔兰。他们不了解那里。坦率地说，虽然这么说很糟糕，但他们并不关心。是的。他们觉得这很令人困惑，新闻也让他们感到沮丧，但他们并不真正理解，也没有投入太多的思考。
And the same is true of the government. You say in State of Emergency that Northern Ireland was not even the government's main priority. So effectively a civil war within the fabric of the United Kingdom and it's not their main priority. Because as we heard in the first episode, Edward Heath has a load of other things on his plate. Well, Edward Heath is struggling with lots of different things. I mean, by the way, the government do spend, particularly somebody like Willie Whitelaw, who's Heath's lieutenant in Northern Ireland. They spend a lot of time on Northern Ireland trying to, as it were, solve it. And they consider all options.
政府也是如此。你在《紧急状态》中提到，北爱尔兰甚至不是政府的首要任务。所以，这实际上是联合王国境内的一场内战，却不是他们的首要任务。因为正如我们在第一集听到的那样，爱德华·希思（Edward Heath）手头还有一大堆其他事情要处理。嗯，爱德华·希思正在为各种不同的事情挣扎。顺便说一句，政府确实投入了大量精力，特别是像威利·怀特劳（Willie Whitelaw）这样的人，他是希思在北爱尔兰的副手。他们在北爱尔兰投入了大量时间，试图解决这个问题。他们考虑了所有方案。
So redrawing the border, giving Northern Ireland more autonomy, giving it less autonomy, even withdrawing from Northern Ireland is an option that's very much on the table in the mid-1970s. And the thing that I hadn't realised, but was reminded reading your books again, is that actually, in a way, most people might think that it's Britain that wants to keep Northern Ireland and it's the Republic of Ireland that wants to get it. But actually, it's the other way around, certainly in the early 1970s. I mean, the Irish foreign minister is hassling Kissinger to lean on the British government not to withdraw. Not to get out. Yeah, not to get out. Amazing. Extraordinary, I know. And we should definitely go into that in greater detail when
所以，重新划分边界、给予北爱尔兰更多自治权、减少自治权，甚至从北爱尔兰撤军，都是70年代中期摆在桌面上的选项。我之前没意识到，但重读你的书后被提醒的一点是，实际上，大多数人可能认为英国想保留北爱尔兰，而爱尔兰共和国想夺回它。但实际上，情况恰恰相反，至少在70年代初是这样。我的意思是，爱尔兰外交部长一直在纠缠基辛格，让他向英国政府施压，要求不要撤军。不要离开。是的，不要离开。太神奇了。我知道，这非常不寻常。我们绝对应该在
we come to a series on the Troubles. But for the time being, it's just worth saying, because this is a podcast series about British politics in 1974, that throughout the rest of the year, there is an IRA bombing pretty much every week in Britain. So on the 13th of February, for example, what is that? Just nine days after the M62 bombing, there is a bomb in Latimer, Buckinghamshire, the National Defence College. Some people are hurt, but nobody is killed. So there is that. There was also the attempts of the British authorities to try and find the culprits. So with the example of the M62 bombing, they effectively coerce a confession out of a mentally ill woman called Judith Ward, a confession that proves to be completely erroneous. And it's not the last time it will happen.
我们制作关于“动乱”（The Troubles）的系列节目时更详细地探讨这一点。但目前值得一提的是，因为这是一个关于1974年英国政治的播客系列，在这一年的剩余时间里，英国几乎每周都会发生一起爱尔兰共和军的爆炸事件。例如，2月13日，那是什么时候？就在M62爆炸案发生仅九天后，白金汉郡拉蒂默的国防学院发生了一起爆炸。有人受伤，但无人死亡。所以确实有这种情况。英国当局也试图寻找罪魁祸首。以M62爆炸案为例，他们实际上从一名患有精神疾病的女子朱迪思·沃德（Judith Ward）那里强迫获得了一份供词，而这份供词后来被证明是完全错误的。这不会是最后一次发生这种情况。
A bomb attack in 1974. Bomb attacks and then terrible miscarriages of justice that will follow. And also just to say that, of course, this is a coach that is taking people from the army. Yes. So from the point of view of the IRA, the army are a particular target. Yeah. But they are also letting off bombs that will target civilians in London.
1974年的炸弹袭击。炸弹袭击，随之而来的是可怕的司法不公。还要说的是，这辆客车运载的是军人。是的。所以从爱尔兰共和军的角度来看，军队是一个特定的目标。是的。但他们也引爆了针对伦敦平民的炸弹。
Department stores, shops, restaurants. And as we will see in due course, pubs as well. And pubs as we will see, exactly. So this is the background to the election that we ended the last episode with, the February 1974 election, which Ted Heath calls three days after the M62 bombing. So as we said, Britain literally feels like a dark place. It's the three-day week, streetlights turned off, no floodlighting, electric sort of neon adverts turned off. You say in your book, nobody could remember an election in grimmer circumstances. Well, nobody can. There's never been an election in people's memory in which the stakes seem higher or the context seems gloomier. Or the chance of a positive outcome.
百货公司、商店、餐馆。正如我们稍后会看到的，还有酒吧。正如我们稍后会看到的，酒吧，没错。这就是我们上一集结尾提到的选举背景，即1974年2月的选举，希思在M62爆炸案发生三天后宣布了选举。正如我们所说，英国感觉就像一个黑暗的地方。实行“三日工作制”，路灯熄灭，没有泛光灯，霓虹灯广告牌也关掉了。你在书中说，没人记得在如此严峻的情况下举行过选举。嗯，确实没人记得。在人们的记忆中，从未有过一场选举看起来赌注如此之高，或者背景如此阴郁。或者出现积极结果的机会。
Yeah. Just seems impossible. Just seems more remote. Because again, you quote the Nuffield study of the election that was written after the election. You say it was an unpopularity contest between two contenders, widely seen as incompetent on the major issues. Yes. So thank goodness that's never happened again. No, that would never happen again in British politics. Exactly. Definitely won't be happening this year.
是的。似乎是不可能的。似乎更加遥远。因为你再次引用了选举后撰写的纳菲尔德（Nuffield）选举研究。你说这是一场两个竞争者之间的“不受欢迎程度竞赛”，在重大问题上被广泛视为无能。是的。所以谢天谢地，这种情况再也没有发生过。不，这种情况在英国政治中再也不会发生了。没错。今年绝对不会发生。
So, right, let's start with Heath. So Heath has called the election and the message of his campaign it's the perfect example the story of what was later to happen to theresa may in 2017 you call an election on one issue and actually you find the public want the election to be on a whole load of other issues you don't control the narrative but anyway heath believes he will control the narrative his theme is going to be that he's the man of destiny the yachtsman steering the nation, Tom, through choppy waters. Towards the rocks. He has this manifesto that basically says, Labour and the unions are far left. They are dangerous. They are a threat to the nation. Union barons is the phrase.
那么，好吧，让我们从希思开始。希思宣布了选举，他的竞选信息是后来特蕾莎·梅在2017年遭遇的完美写照：你为了一个议题宣布选举，结果发现公众希望选举围绕一大堆其他议题进行，你无法控制叙事。但无论如何，希思相信他能控制叙事。他的主题将是他是一个命运之子，汤姆，掌舵着国家穿过波涛汹涌的水域。驶向礁石。他的竞选纲领基本上说，工党和工会是极左派。他们很危险。他们是对国家的威胁。“工会男爵”是当时的用语。
The union barons. Yeah. The union barons was absolutely the uh the daily express phrase du jour over mighty subjects yes so that's what he says once you know young men who are writing heath's manifesto and more on nigel lawson douglas heard people who would become ministers later for margaret thatcher heath himself is actually quite uneasy with all this because he as we said last time is a corporatist by instinct a kind of a paternalist a technocrat and actually they will send him out to go and give speeches and they'll say go and get people really excited about how terrible the unions are and stuff and actually he'll just revert to his default and start talking about you know to get around the table moderation
工会男爵。是的，“工会男爵”绝对是《每日快报》当时的流行语，指那些权势滔天的人。是的，这就是他所说的。你知道，那些为希思撰写竞选纲领的年轻人，还有更多关于奈杰尔·劳森（Nigel Lawson）、道格拉斯·赫德（Douglas Hurd）等后来成为玛格丽特·撒切尔内阁大臣的人。希思本人实际上对这一切感到相当不安，因为正如我们上次所说，他本能上是一个社团主义者，一种家长式作风的专家治国论者。实际上，他们会派他出去发表演讲，让他们说去让人们对工会是多么糟糕感到非常兴奋，而实际上他只会回归本色，开始谈论围坐在桌旁、温和、
sensible people and stuff so his advisors are slightly kind of pulling their hair out. However, the good news for them is that they're not the Labour Party, because the Labour Party, which is the opposition, seem to be in a terrible state. And this is where we should introduce a tremendous character in this week's podcast, who is Harold Wilson, Heath's rival. Yeah. Exactly the same age, born in 1916. His father was an industrial chemist from Huddersfield, and he'd gone off to Oxford, and he'd been an absolute intellectual star at Oxford. He's supposedly, Tom, got the highest mark ever in his economics papers and became an economics don at Oxford when he was about 12.
理智的人等等。所以他的顾问们有点抓狂。然而，对他们来说好消息是，他们不是工党，因为作为反对党的工党似乎处于一种糟糕的状态。这就是我们应该在本周的播客中介绍一位了不起的人物的时候了，他就是哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson），希思的竞争对手。是的。年龄完全一样，出生于1916年。他的父亲是哈德斯菲尔德的一名工业化学家，他去了牛津，在牛津绝对是一个知识明星。汤姆，据说他在经济学论文中获得了有史以来最高的成绩，并在大约12岁时就成为了牛津大学的经济学讲师。
Yes. And then became a kind of government statistician, a backroom boy. He became a big rising star in Clement Attlee's Labour government. Everyone says of Harold Wilson, he's very cunning. You can't completely trust him,
是的。然后他成为了一名政府统计学家，一个幕后操盘手。他成为了克莱门特·艾德礼（Clement Attlee）工党政府中一颗冉冉升起的新星。每个人都说哈罗德·威尔逊非常狡猾。你不能完全信任他，
but he's a very decent man, Wilson, in some ways. He's kind-hearted, isn't he? Kind-hearted. I always say, Wilson is the man you want as your neighbour. He's the man that your lawnmower is broken. You want to borrow a lawnmower. Harold Wilson will lend you his lawnmower with a cheery smile.
但在某些方面，威尔逊是一个非常正派的人。他心地善良，不是吗？心地善良。我总是说，威尔逊是你想要的那种邻居。他是那种你的割草机坏了，你想借用割草机时的人。哈罗德·威尔逊会带着灿烂的笑容把他的割草机借给你。
If you don't give it back straight away, that's fine. You can go round and have a drink with him a few days later. Take the lawnmower back. Have a lovely time. He's quite suburban, Harold Wilson. So all his Labour colleagues slightly despise him. Because he has tinned salmon, doesn't he? His tinned salmon, what he claims to to prefer tinned salmon to smoked salmon.
如果你没有马上还给他，那也没关系。几天后你可以过去和他喝一杯。把割草机还回去。度过一段愉快的时光。哈罗德·威尔逊相当具有郊区气息。所以他所有的工党同事都有点鄙视他。因为他吃罐装鲑鱼，不是吗？他的罐装鲑鱼，他声称更喜欢罐装鲑鱼而不是烟熏鲑鱼。
You imply that he genuinely did. I think he probably, there is a pooterish side to him. So he likes Agatha Christie. Yeah. He likes playing golf. He's a very Sandbrookian figure. Thanks. Thanks. I don't play golf. No, but these are your people, Dominic. Yeah.
你暗示他确实是这样。我想他可能，他身上有一种普特（Pooterish，指平庸、自命不凡）的一面。所以他喜欢阿加莎·克里斯蒂。是的。他喜欢打高尔夫球。他是一个非常桑德布鲁克式的人物。谢谢。谢谢。我不打高尔夫球。不，但这些人是你的同类，多米尼克。是的。
Well, they're the heroes of your books. They're the kind of people who are making modern Britain and who often get written out of the narrative. Theo has texted in the chat, he loves the garden centre. And that's absolutely right. Well, I tell you what he really loves, of course, he loves the Boy Scout. And I mean that not in a sinister way. Tom, wow, what a revelation.
好吧，他们是你书中的英雄。他们是那种正在塑造现代英国，却经常被排除在叙事之外的人。西奥在聊天中发短信说，他喜欢园艺中心。这完全正确。好吧，我告诉你他真正喜欢什么，当然，他喜欢童子军。我说的不是那种阴险的方式。汤姆，哇，真是个启示。
I mean, you say that he's inspired by scouting far more than he is by socialism. And there are always extraordinary photos of him wearing unbelievably tight boy scout star shorts. Because he goes on holiday to the silly isles off the coast of Cornwall every year. Which is a very, very kind of Britain in 1974 kind of destination. It is. And he will wear these shorts, sort of khaki shorts, and he'll tuck his shirt into the shorts very tightly and smoke his pipe
我的意思是，你说他受童子军运动的启发远多于受社会主义的启发。而且总有一些他穿着令人难以置信的紧身童子军短裤的非凡照片。因为他每年都去康沃尔海岸外的锡利群岛度假。这是一种非常、非常1974年英国式的目的地。确实。他会穿这些短裤，那种卡其色短裤，把衬衫紧紧地塞进短裤里，抽着烟斗，
and sit on the rocks with his boys. That's absolutely how it was. He was supposedly the Queen's favourite Prime Minister, wasn't he? Yeah, because of all this, because of the garden centre. And also, Tom... But he's kind and he's funny, as well as having a certain animal cunning.
和他的孩子们坐在岩石上。情况绝对就是这样。据说他是女王最喜欢的首相，不是吗？是的，因为这一切，因为园艺中心。还有，汤姆……但他既善良又风趣，同时也有一种动物般的狡黠。
He wins four out of five elections that he fights. So actually, the British people would look at Wilson. I mean, some people despise Wilson, sort of businessman and stuff. And indeed, members of the security services, as we'll find out. Exactly. But I think a lot of ordinary people not interested in politics looked at Harold Wilson. They thought, ah, good old Harold. He's like me. He's not really interested in politics. Great. Good for him. And of course, I mean, his greatest achievement to give the
他参加的五次选举中赢了四次。所以实际上，英国人民会看着威尔逊。我的意思是，有些人鄙视威尔逊，那种商人什么的。确实，安全部门的人也是，正如我们将要发现的那样。没错。但我认为很多对政治不感兴趣的普通人看着哈罗德·威尔逊。他们想，啊，好老哈罗德。他就像我一样。他其实对政治不感兴趣。太棒了。对他来说很好。当然，我的意思是，他最大的成就是给
Beatles MBEs. Yes. And to keep Britain out of Vietnam. Two great achievements. Anyway, poor old Harold Wilson, who had won power in 1964 as the man who was going to modernise Britain, wearing a sort of Macintosh, plastic Mac. Is it a Gamix? Gamix. Gamix. Gamix Mac. The white-eater technology. He is very shop-soiled by 1974.
披头士乐队颁发大英帝国勋章（MBE）。是的。并让英国远离越南。两大成就。无论如何，可怜的哈罗德·威尔逊，他在1964年以现代化英国的人的身份赢得了权力，穿着一种麦金托什雨衣，塑料雨衣。是Gamix吗？Gamix。Gamix。Gamix雨衣。白热化的技术。到1974年，他已经非常陈旧了。
He's knackered. He looks like he's sort of aged a thousand years. He's really bruised from having been defeated in 1970 by Heath, but he's somehow managed to cling on to the Labour leadership. And in due course, he will succumb to Alzheimer's. He will do, yes. And are there not theories that even at this point, he is starting to suffer memory loss? Or do you think not?
他精疲力竭。他看起来好像老了一千岁。他在1970年被希思击败后确实受到了打击，但他不知何故设法保住了工党领袖的职位。最终，他会患上阿尔茨海默病。他会的，是的。有没有理论认为即使在这一点上，他已经开始出现记忆力减退了？还是你认为没有？
I think probably not memory loss at this point. But it is certainly true that the people who are around him, who are closest to him, so there's his press secretary, Joe Haynes, his policy advisor, Bernard Donoghue, who have written very detailed memoirs and diaries about this period. They would say, you know, he's not what he was. He's tired. He doesn't always do his homework. He sort of sometimes does forget things. He drinks too much. All this kind of stuff. Now, whether, you know, this really is prefiguring the Alzheimer's or whether this is merely the exhaustion and the sort of the weariness that come from a long career in politics, it's hard to say. And which Heath also is suffering from. Which Heath is also suffering from, of course. Exactly. I think it's a sign of the pressures of the 70s what's happened though is that when labour left office the party had swung you know as so often it had swung well to the left and in
我想现在可能还没有记忆力减退。但确实，他身边最亲近的人，比如他的新闻秘书乔·海恩斯（Joe Haynes），他的政策顾问伯纳德·多诺霍（Bernard Donoghue），他们写了关于这段时期的非常详细的回忆录和日记。他们会说，你知道，他已经不是以前的他了。他累了。他并不总是做功课。他有时确实会忘记事情。他喝得太多。所有这些事情。现在，这是否真的预示着阿尔茨海默病，还是仅仅是长期政治生涯带来的疲惫和厌倦，很难说。希思也遭受着同样的困扰。希思当然也遭受着同样的困扰。没错。我认为这是70年代压力的一个标志，但发生的事情是，当工党离开政府时，该党已经转向了，正如它经常做的那样，它已经向左转了，在
those days the direction of the party was determined not so much by the leader but by the national executive committee and by the party conferences they would decide the policies and they would decide the manifesto whether the leader liked it or not. So actually, when Heath calls that election, Labour, which is a party becoming increasingly torn apart between its sort of more middle-class, high-minded parliamentary representatives and the union leaders and the ordinary activists. So this is the classic division that you've often mentioned before between the prune juice drinking sandal wearers.
那些日子里，党的方向不是由领袖决定的，而是由全国执行委员会和党代会决定的。他们会决定政策，他们会决定竞选纲领，不管领袖喜不喜欢。所以实际上，当希思宣布那次选举时，工党，一个在其中产阶级、高尚的议会代表与工会领袖和普通活动家之间日益撕裂的政党。所以这就是你之前经常提到的经典的“喝西梅汁的穿凉鞋的人”之间的分裂。
Yes. And the horny handed sons of toil. Exactly. Exactly so. It is becoming more and more sort of pulled apart. Not to stereotype in any way, but... No, but I mean... Yeah, it is a division. These are stereotypes that people used a lot of the time.
是的。和“长满老茧的劳动之子”。没错。没错。它正变得越来越被拉扯。并不是要以任何方式刻板印象，但是……不，但我的意思是……是的，这是一种分裂。这些是人们当时经常使用的刻板印象。
Yeah. And it's got a manifesto that has been drawn up by the left of the party that commits the Labour Party, formerly technocratic under Wilson in the 60s, to a fundamental and irreversible shift in the balance of power and wealth in favour of working people and their families. So this famous line. for this is a man called Tony Ben, who will be familiar to regular listeners of the podcast because he was the winner of the second historical Love Island, wasn't he? He was. Who did he win it with? Mary Fisher. She was a top Quaker. So it was a very earnest
是的。它有一个由党内左翼起草的竞选纲领，承诺工党——在60年代威尔逊领导下曾是技术官僚——将实现权力与财富平衡的根本性和不可逆转的转变，以有利于劳动人民及其家庭。所以这句名言。为此，有一个叫托尼·本（Tony Benn）的人，他对于播客的常客来说很熟悉，因为他是第二届历史版《恋爱岛》的获胜者，不是吗？他是。他和谁一起赢的？玛丽·费舍尔（Mary Fisher）。她是一位顶尖的贵格会教徒。所以这是一个非常认真的
pairing. He's very earnest, Tony Ben. He was formerly Viscount Stansgate. He renounced his peerage and he's reinvented himself as the Tribune of the Plebs. He walks around in a kind of parka and a rack, shaking hands with shop stewards and with people on picket lines and saying he can't wait to basically nationalize everything. Indeed, he does want to nationalize everything. So Tony Benn has got this staggering plan. Labour, when they get in, are going to create something called the National Enterprise Board.
组合。他非常认真，托尼·本。他曾是斯坦斯盖特子爵（Viscount Stansgate）。他放弃了贵族头衔，把自己重塑为平民保民官。他穿着一种派克大衣，四处走动，与工会代表和纠察线上的人握手，说他迫不及待地想把一切国有化。确实，他确实想把一切国有化。所以托尼·本有一个惊人的计划。工党一旦上台，将建立一个名为“国家企业委员会”（National Enterprise Board）的机构。
And the National Enterprise Board, which sounds very boring, what it will actually do is it will force all of industry to sign planning agreements with the government. So five-year plans and stuff. Ben wants to have an Emergency Powers Act and an Emergency Industrial Act that will allow him to take over the top 25 companies in Britain. And effectively run them himself from Whitehall. And a lot of his own Labour colleagues think this is absolutely bonkers. So my favourite line, which will be completely lost on our overseas list, is Dennis Healey, who is the shadow chancellor, said to him, yeah, what a brilliant idea. Why don't we nationalise Marks and Spencers to make it as good as the co-op? Because Marks and Spencer is slightly top end and the co-op isn't.
而国家企业委员会，听起来很无聊，但它实际上会做的是，它将强迫所有工业部门与政府签署规划协议。所以五年计划之类的。本想要一项《紧急权力法》和一项《紧急工业法》，允许他接管英国前25大公司。并实际上由他自己从白厅（Whitehall）进行管理。他自己的许多工党同事认为这绝对是疯了。所以我最喜欢的一句话，对于我们的海外听众来说完全无法理解，是影子财政大臣丹尼斯·希利（Dennis Healey）对他说，是的，真是个好主意。为什么我们不把玛莎百货（Marks and Spencers）国有化，让它变得和合作社（co-op）一样好呢？因为玛莎百货稍微高端一点，而合作社不是。
And Tony Benn was very offended by this and said, this shows that Dennis is actually very right wing and capitalist running dog and all this sort of stuff. But this is the plan that Labour are going to the public with. They're going to nationalise those things. They're going to force companies to sign planning agreements. This in the context of the massive inflation and the credit crisis and all of that stuff. But also, Tom, they're going to have a referendum on leaving the European common market. Madness. And Britain's only been in for a year.
托尼·本对此感到非常冒犯，并说这表明丹尼斯实际上是一个非常右翼和资本主义的走狗，所有这些东西。但这就是工党要向公众提出的计划。他们要将这些东西国有化。他们要强迫公司签署规划协议。这是在通货膨胀、信贷危机和所有这些事情的背景下。但汤姆，他们还要就退出欧洲共同市场进行全民公投。疯狂。而英国才加入了一年。
Yeah. Tony Benko, they say, oh, this is a terrible capitalist plot. It's a capitalist plot by pampered European fat cats. Well, I mean, he's not entirely wrong. The European Union is, as it becomes, is very capitalist, isn't it? I suppose it is. I mean, so Jeremy Corbyn,
是的。托尼·本说，哦，这是一个可怕的资本主义阴谋。这是被宠坏的欧洲肥猫的资本主义阴谋。好吧，我的意思是，他并不完全错误。欧洲联盟，正如它后来成为的那样，是非常资本主义的，不是吗？我想是的。我的意思是，所以杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn），
who in a way is Tony Benn's kind of political heir, almost certainly, I'm pretty sure, voted to leave in the more recent referendum. Yes, exactly. Exactly right, Tom. So if you're a pro-European, the thought of Labour winning power on this kind of agenda is quite worrying. It was genuinely very worrying.
他在某种程度上是托尼·本的政治继承人，几乎可以肯定，我很确定，他投票支持在最近的公投中离开。是的，完全正确，汤姆。所以如果你是一个亲欧派，想到工党带着这种议程赢得权力是相当令人担忧的。这确实非常令人担忧。
And of course, this is the most radical agenda that anybody has really gone to the public with since, what, 1945? Arguably even longer, because someone like Tony Benn seems to the press to be a Bolshevik, you know, a sort of somebody who is going to turn Britain into a North Korea. All this stuff that you see in the newspapers. Well, Warsaw Pact country, kind of East Germany or... East Germany, exactly. Exactly. But isn't, ironically, the figure in the Labour Party who comes up with the phrase that articulates this sense of dread on the part of the middle classes and so on, is actually Dennis Healy, who made the joke about Marks and Spencer.
当然，这是自1945年以来任何人真正向公众提出的最激进的议程？可以说甚至更久，因为像托尼·本这样的人在媒体看来就像一个布尔什维克，你知道，一个要把英国变成朝鲜的人。所有这些你在报纸上看到的东西。嗯，华沙条约国家，某种东德或者……东德，没错。没错。但讽刺的是，工党内部提出那个表达中产阶级这种恐惧感的短语的人，实际上是丹尼斯·希利，就是那个开玛莎百货玩笑的人。
Because he comes up with the famous phrase that his aim is to squeeze the rich and make the pips squeak. And it's that phrase, making the pips squeak, that kind of gets written up by the Daily Mail, Daily Express, Telegraph. Exactly. So Dennis Healey, who actually is going to turn out to be a much more pragmatic chancellor and arguably much more sort of right wing than anybody anticipated. What's happened is that the sort of left wing mood has sort of seeped into the rhetoric of even people on the right of the Labour Party. Actually, what he says is, we're going to squeeze property developers until the pipsqueak. But that, as you say, is written up as, they're going to squeeze the rich and the middle classes. Oh no, what a disaster. Of course, this is at a time when taxes are very, very high. So the highest rate of income tax is
因为他提出了那句名言，说他的目标是“挤压富人，直到他们发出尖叫”（squeeze the rich and make the pips squeak）。正是那句“让果核发出尖叫”，被《每日邮报》、《每日快报》、《每日电讯报》大肆报道。没错。所以丹尼斯·希利，他实际上将成为一个务实得多的财政大臣，而且可以说比任何人预期的都要右翼得多。发生的事情是，那种左翼情绪已经渗入了即使是工党右翼人士的言论中。实际上，他说的是，我们要挤压房地产开发商，直到他们发出尖叫。但正如你所说，这被写成了“他们要挤压富人和中产阶级”。哦不，真是灾难。当然，这是在税收非常非常高的时候。所以最高所得税率是
83%, Tom. And so Dennis Healey, he kind of storms the beaches at Anzio. Yes. Friend of Edward Heath, as you said in the first part. Yeah. Always boasting about his hinterland. Yeah. Always kind of dropping poets into conversations. Yeah, he'll talk about Flaubert or Turgenev or something and annoy people by doing that. And I was startled to learn from your book that one of his favourite things to do at weekends was to answer the phone in the broken English of a Chinese laundry proprietor.
83%，汤姆。所以丹尼斯·希利，他有点像冲上了安齐奥（Anzio）的海滩。是的。爱德华·希思的朋友，正如你在第一部分所说。是的。总是吹嘘他的背景。是的。总是把诗人带进谈话中。是的，他会谈论福楼拜（Flaubert）或屠格涅夫（Turgenev）之类的东西，并因此惹恼人们。我从你的书中惊讶地发现，他周末最喜欢做的事情之一是用中国洗衣店老板蹩脚的英语接电话。
Yes. That was unexpected. So Dennis Healy broken English of a Chinese laundry proprietor. Yes. That was unexpected. So Dennis Healy is one of my favourite people, Tom, I've ever lived with. Huge eyebrows. Massive eyebrows. He went to the same Oxford College as Ted Heath. And you. And me.
是的。那是意想不到的。所以丹尼斯·希利，中国洗衣店老板的蹩脚英语。是的。那是意想不到的。所以丹尼斯·希利是我最喜欢的人之一，汤姆，我曾经生活过的人。巨大的眉毛。浓密的眉毛。他和泰德·希思（Ted Heath）上了同一所牛津学院。还有你。还有我。
And indeed, Roy Stewart from the rest of politics. So all good. He's a great family man. He does spend all his time hanging around in the House of Commons. He likes to go home and be with his family, which I admire. Like Tony Benn. Also very uxorious. Like Tony Benn. But unlike Tony Benn, he's an enormous bully. So he's extremely rude to other Labour MPs. He'll deliberately drop in conversation, references to Tolstoy.
还有《历史的余味》里的罗伊·斯图尔特（Roy Stewart）。所以都很好。他是一个伟大的顾家男人。他确实把所有时间都花在下议院周围。他喜欢回家和家人在一起，我很钦佩这一点。像托尼·本一样。也非常宠爱妻子。像托尼·本一样。但与托尼·本不同的是，他是一个巨大的恶霸。所以他对其他工党议员非常粗鲁。他会故意在谈话中插入对托尔斯泰的引用。
Quotes from Yeats. Yeah, quotes from Yeats. Exactly. He does exactly what Dennis Healy does. Yeah. But then he'll also try to have fights with them. You know, he's a bruiser. He'll F and blind at them. I just think he's an absolutely splendid man at top. Dennis Healy is the man I would like to be, to be honest with you.
叶芝（Yeats）的引语。是的，叶芝的引语。没错。他做的正是丹尼斯·希利所做的。是的。但他也会试图和他们打架。你知道，他是一个打手。他会对着他们大骂。我只是觉得他是一个绝对出色的人，汤姆。丹尼斯·希利是我想要成为的人，老实说。
Yeah, I can see that, Dominic. I can see that. So anyway, that's the Labour Party. They've got their tremendously left-wing manifesto. Nobody thinks they're going to win, really, but people are terrified in the city, in business and so on. They're absolutely terrified about the prospects if they do. So if you are rich in February 1974, if you work in the City of London, if you own a business, things are looking very, very bleak for you. Taxes are very high.
是的，我能看出来，多米尼克。我能看出来。所以无论如何，这就是工党。他们有他们极其左翼的竞选纲领。没人认为他们会赢，真的，但人们在伦敦金融城、商界等等感到恐惧。他们对如果工党获胜的前景感到非常恐惧。所以如果你在1974年2月很富有，如果你在伦敦金融城工作，如果你拥有一家企业，情况对你来说看起来非常非常暗淡。税收非常高。
Inflation is through the roof. There's been a property bubble that has now burst. There has been a banking bubble, which has also burst. So there are all these secondary banks in the city of London, the value of which has dropped in some cases by a third or half in the last few months. The news is full of bombings and stuff. The press is absolutely hysterical. I mean, people moan about newspapers now and on social media, people will laugh at what they see as newspaper exaggerations and things. But if you had read the papers in February, 1974, you would genuinely think that there was either a communist revolution or a kind of Weimar style meltdown probably happening on Monday. So you print some of the cartoons from this
通货膨胀高得离谱。曾经有一个房地产泡沫，现在已经破裂了。有一个银行泡沫，也破裂了。所以伦敦金融城里有所有这些二级银行，在过去几个月里，有些银行的价值下降了三分之一或一半。新闻里到处都是爆炸案之类的。媒体绝对是歇斯底里的。我的意思是，人们现在抱怨报纸，在社交媒体上，人们会嘲笑他们所看到的报纸夸大其词之类的事情。但如果你在1974年2月读过报纸，你会真诚地认为周一可能会发生共产主义革命或某种魏玛风格的崩溃。所以你印了一些来自这个
election campaign in state of emergency, one of which is Tony Benn as an SS member carrying a whip, which I can't imagine anyone doing now, that kind of thing. No, very full on kind of cartoons. Or there's one in which Tony Benn is drawn with his plans for industry and taking over businesses. He is drawn. There's no way of sugarcoating this. He's drawn as a rapist dragging a woman by her hair. The woman is Britain or British industry.
选举活动的漫画，在《紧急状态》中，其中一个是托尼·本作为党卫军成员挥舞着鞭子，我无法想象现在有人会这样做，那种事情。不，非常激进的漫画。或者有一个漫画，托尼·本被画成带着他的工业计划和接管企业的计划。他被画了出来。没有办法美化这一点。他被画成一个强奸犯，拖着一个女人的头发。那个女人是英国或英国工业。
And the woman is saying, no, no, no. And Tony Benn is saying, it's all for the good of the nation or something like this. I mean, just an extraordinarily incendiary cartoon. But in the context of early 1974, absolutely par for the course. People didn't even complain. Okay. So basically things are absolutely terrible for which clearly Heath bears a massive responsibility because he's been in power for the previous four years. But the argument is that Labour would make it even worse. That's essentially the position of the press.
那个女人在说，不，不，不。而托尼·本在说，这一切都是为了国家的好处之类的。我的意思是，这只是一幅极其煽动性的漫画。但在1974年初的背景下，绝对是常态。人们甚至没有抱怨。好的。所以基本上情况对希思来说绝对是糟糕的，因为他在过去四年里一直掌权，他负有巨大的责任。但论点是工党会使情况变得更糟。这基本上是媒体的立场。
Even people within the Labour Party, the high command of the Labour Party, think they're going to lose and actually don't really want to win. So Roy Jenkins, who had been Wilson's Chancellor, yet another university friend of Ted Heath. He just thinks we're going to lose and we deserve to lose. We don't have any sensible plans other than basically bribing the miners to go back to work. We don't have any answer to the crisis that we're in. So on the one hand, you have some of these people on the left of the Labour Party who are seized with this kind of real sense of excitement. They want to rebuild Britain and they've got these great plans to do it. On the right,
即使是工党内部的人，工党的高层，也认为他们会输，实际上并不真的想赢。所以罗伊·詹金斯（Roy Jenkins），他曾是威尔逊的财政大臣，又是泰德·希思的另一位大学朋友。他只是认为我们要输了，而且我们活该输。除了基本上贿赂矿工回去工作之外，我们没有任何明智的计划。我们对我们所处的危机没有任何答案。所以一方面，你有一些工党左翼的人，他们被这种真正的兴奋感所抓住。他们想重建英国，他们有这些伟大的计划来实现它。在右翼，
they were part of people who were very depressed. Harold Wilson himself is terribly hanged dog. He's sort of doing these tours of working men's clubs and sort of places in the north of England and stuff.
他们是那些非常沮丧的人的一部分。哈罗德·威尔逊本人非常垂头丧气。他正在做这些工人俱乐部和英格兰北部之类地方的巡回演出。
And he's like an old musical comedian. My dog's got no nose. Yeah. How does it smell? Take my mother-in-law. Oh, go on, take her. So he's sort of doing these last routines and then he'll go off into retirement. Right.
他就像一个老音乐喜剧演员。我的狗没有鼻子。是的。它是怎么闻的？带上我的岳母。哦，去吧，带上她。所以他正在做这些最后的例行公事，然后他就会退休。好的。
So basically, it looks as though the Conservatives are going to win. Yeah. That his scamble is paying off. There seems very little prospect of a Labour victory. But, ladies and gentlemen, is that actually the case? We will find out after the break. What a cliffhanger. I'm Marina Hyde.
所以基本上，看起来保守党要赢了。是的。他的赌博正在得到回报。工党获胜的前景似乎很小。但是，女士们先生们，事实真的如此吗？休息后我们将揭晓。真是个悬念。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are looking at 1974, the worst year in modern British political history, according to top historian of the period, Dominic Sandbrook. And Dominic, we're looking at the first election campaign of 1974, and things seem to be going well for Edward Heath and the Conservatives, despite the fact that they've messed everything up. Are there any kind of chinks of light that might give Harold Wilson and Labour any encouragement at all? Tom, there are.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在审视1974年，根据该时期顶级历史学家多米尼克·桑德布鲁克的说法，这是现代英国政治史上最糟糕的一年。多米尼克，我们正在审视1974年的第一次选举活动，尽管爱德华·希思和保守党把一切都搞砸了，但事情似乎进展顺利。有没有什么一线希望可以给哈罗德·威尔逊和工党带来一点鼓励？汤姆，有的。
There are. Are there? So the polls are pretty much, they're vaguely neck and neck. The Tories are normally ahead. So sometimes the Tories are ahead by 5% or so. And Heath's strategists think, you know, people don't place as much store by opinion polls in the early 70s as they do today. And presumably they're not as common. They're not as common and they're not as accurate, frankly.
有的。真的吗？所以民意调查基本上是模糊的势均力敌。保守党通常领先。所以有时保守党领先5%左右。希思的战略家们认为，你知道，人们在70年代初不像今天这样重视民意调查。而且大概它们没那么普遍。它们没那么普遍，坦率地说，它们也不那么准确。
So Heath's advisors are pretty confident that by the time the public vote, they will get a margin of victory, you know, 5%, maybe 10% that they will do it. And almost everybody in the press thinks that. However, there are, as you say, chinks of light for Harold Wilson. First of all, there is another party tom that we haven't mentioned our old friends the liberal party led by yeah very much a friend of the show jeremy thorpe dog killing yes yeah we we did a podcast about jeremy thorpe's bizarre i don't know how to describe it because it's so Baroque.
所以希思的顾问们相当自信，到公众投票时，他们会获得一个胜利的优势，你知道，5%，也许10%，他们会做到的。几乎所有媒体的人都这么认为。然而，正如你所说，哈罗德·威尔逊有一线希望。首先，还有另一个政党，汤姆，我们还没提到我们的老朋友自由党，由……是的，非常是节目的朋友，杰里米·索普（Jeremy Thorpe），那个杀狗的。是的，是的，我们做了一个关于杰里米·索普的播客，非常离奇，我不知道该怎么形容，因为它太巴洛克了。
He'd had a relationship with a stable hand called Norman Scott, who thought that Jeremy Thorpe had stolen his national insurance card. Jeremy Thorpe then conspired to have him murdered by a fruit machine salesman. Yeah, by a fruit machine salesman
他和一名叫诺曼·斯科特（Norman Scott）的马夫有过一段关系，诺曼·斯科特认为杰里米·索普偷了他的国民保险卡。杰里米·索普随后密谋让一名水果机推销员谋杀他。是的，由一名水果机推销员
and carpet salesman. They were either going to drop him down a mine shaft. They were going to to drop him down a mine shaft. They were going to have him fed to alligators in the Florida Everglades. Or they were going to poison him in the pub. Remember, he was going to fall off his bar stool in the pub. Yeah. They didn't do all that.
和地毯推销员。他们要么要把他扔进矿井。他们要把他扔进矿井。他们要把他喂给佛罗里达大沼泽地的短吻鳄。或者他们要在酒吧里毒死他。记住，他要在酒吧里从高脚凳上摔下来。是的。他们没做所有这些。
They ended up murdering his dog instead. They got an airline pilot to murder his dog. And it went to trial and Thorpe got off. But this is all later. Yeah. And you can hear it in, I think, the first episode we did on British politics in the 70s. I think that's right. Yeah. It's a fabulous episode. So anyway, at this point, Jeremy Thorpe, he's a bounder, isn't he, Tom? Yeah. He is an absolute... A cad.
他们最终谋杀了他的狗。他们找了一个航空公司飞行员去谋杀他的狗。案件上了法庭，索普脱罪了。但这都是后来的事了。是的。你可以在我想我们做的第一集关于70年代英国政治的节目中听到。我想那是对的。是的。这是一集精彩的节目。所以无论如何，在这一点上，杰里米·索普，他是个无赖，不是吗，汤姆？是的。他绝对是一个……一个坏蛋。
A cad and a bounder in a very amusing way. He's a kind of Captain Hook style Etonian. Except he has two hands. And he's not the one who's being chased by large reptiles with huge teeth. No, he plans to set reptiles on other people. And he's also not a pirate. But he's the leader of the Liberal Party. Well, although, I mean, he's fond of a sea-going vessel, isn't he? Because in the second election, he's a great enthusiast for hovercraft.
一个以非常有趣的方式出现的坏蛋和无赖。他是一个像胡克船长（Captain Hook）那样的伊顿公学毕业生。除了他有两只手。而且他不是那个被长着大牙齿的大型爬行动物追赶的人。不，他计划让爬行动物去对付别人。而且他也不是海盗。但他却是自由党的领袖。好吧，虽然，我的意思是，他喜欢远洋船只，不是吗？因为在第二次选举中，他是气垫船的狂热爱好者。
He is, he is. The parallels, I think, are not far-fetched. Uncanny. So he leads the Liberal Party. He's very jolly. He's very amusing. As you think, are not far-fetched. Uncanny. So he leads the Liberal Party. He's very jolly. He's very amusing. As you say, he's very droll and wry. He'd been at Oxford with all these other people exactly at the same time, bizarrely.
他是，他是。我认为这些相似之处并不牵强。不可思议。所以他领导自由党。他非常快乐。他非常有趣。正如你所说，他非常滑稽和讽刺。奇怪的是，他和其他所有这些人同时在牛津大学。
Or not bizarrely. I mean, that's how Britain works. And he leads the Liberal Party, which kind of don't really stand for anything. They stand for Europe, proportional representation, and sort of being generally nice. Being nice. Yeah, being nice. Apart from the murdering Staplehand side. Yeah.
或者说并不奇怪。我的意思是，这就是英国的运作方式。他领导着自由党，这个党其实什么立场都没有。他们支持欧洲、支持比例代表制，还有就是表现得和蔼可亲。表现得和蔼可亲。是的，表现得和蔼可亲。除了那个谋杀斯泰普汉德（Staplehand）的插曲之外。是的。
And all the time during this election, their ratings are steadily going up, day after day after day. Well, because if you think Heath's messed everything up, Wilson's going to mess everything up. Who else do you have to vote for, I guess? Exactly right. Exactly. Now, as we said, another chink of light for Harold Wilson is the three-day week has not turned out as melodramatic as people envisaged. So a lot of firms, they've made it
在整个选举期间，他们的支持率一天比一天稳步上升。嗯，因为如果你认为希思把一切都搞砸了，威尔逊也会把一切都搞砸。我想，你还能投给谁呢？完全正确。确实。现在，正如我们所说，哈罗德·威尔逊的另一线曙光是，三天工作制并没有人们预想的那么戏剧化。所以很多公司，他们已经做到了
work. They're using candles and all this kind of thing. The weather is much milder. And so people think maybe it was really unnecessary. And maybe the election is unnecessary as well. Heath's been very annoying. I'm sick of Heath. Yeah. So there's your Theresa May parallel again. There's your Theresa May parallel. She went to the is unnecessary as well. Heath's being very annoying. I'm sick of Heath. Yeah. So there's your Theresa May parallel again. There's your Theresa May parallel. She went to the country early as well. Yes.
正常运转。他们在使用蜡烛之类的东西。天气也温和多了。所以人们认为这可能确实是不必要的。也许选举也是不必要的。希思一直很烦人。我受够了希思。是的。所以这又是一个特蕾莎·梅的平行案例。这就是特蕾莎·梅的平行案例。她也提前进行了大选。是的。
Then a bombshell time. We love a bombshell on the rest of history. A metaphorical bombshell, not a real one. On the 21st of February, the pay board, which is one of these very Heathite corporatist bodies, reports and actually says, you know what? Actually, the miners are a bit underpaid. We probably should give the miners more money. That's helpful for Heath. So that's incredibly unhelpful.
然后是重磅炸弹时刻。我们喜欢《历史的其余部分》里的重磅炸弹。隐喻意义上的重磅炸弹，不是真的炸弹。2月21日，薪酬委员会——这是希思那种法团主义机构之一——发布报告，实际上说，你知道吗？其实，矿工们的工资有点低。我们或许应该给矿工更多的钱。这对希思有帮助。所以这简直是帮倒忙。
That couldn't be less unhelpful. Anyway, they get to the end of the penultimate week. So we get to the weekend of the 23rd, 24th of February. The election's going to be on the 28th. And Heath is still very optimistic. The polls are still putting him 5% clear. And then we have an intervention. I mean, British politics in the 70s
这简直不能再帮倒忙了。总之，他们到了倒数第二周的末尾。所以我们到了2月23日、24日的周末。选举将在28日举行。希思仍然非常乐观。民调显示他仍然领先5%。然后我们有了一次干预。我的意思是，70年代的英国政治
is full of such bonkers characters. And now we have perhaps the most, certainly the most controversial and one of the most interesting characters of all. And that is the Member of Parliament for the great city, not that it was a city then, of Wolverhampton, Wolverhampton Southwest, a man of Birmingham, Tom, like the Holland family ancestors, I believe. And the Sandbrookes, right?
充满了这样疯狂的人物。现在我们有了也许是最具争议、也是最有趣的人物之一。那就是伟大的城市——虽然当时还不是城市——伍尔弗汉普顿（Wolverhampton），伍尔弗汉普顿西南选区的国会议员，一个伯明翰人，汤姆，就像荷兰家族的祖先一样，我相信。还有桑德布鲁克家族，对吧？
Well, we're more black country, to be honest. And this is Enoch Powell. So Enoch Powell. Yeah. How do you explain Enoch Powell, Tom? So Enoch Powell, probably best known as a translator of Herodotus. The youngest professor of Greek in the British Empire. Yes. Great scholar of Herodotus, but then went on to become a very significant figure in the Tory party, didn't he?
嗯，老实说，我们更属于黑乡（Black Country）。这就是伊诺克·鲍威尔（Enoch Powell）。所以是伊诺克·鲍威尔。是的。汤姆，你如何解释伊诺克·鲍威尔？所以伊诺克·鲍威尔，可能最出名的是作为希罗多德的译者。大英帝国最年轻的希腊语教授。是的。希罗多德的伟大研究者，但后来成为了保守党中非常重要的人物，不是吗？
He did. And actually, I mean, it's a joke. He's not really best known for Herodotus. He's best known for his Rivers of Blood speech, where he predicted that the result of immigration into Britain would be kind of race war. Yes, exactly right. In 1968. So he was kicked out of the Tory. So he sacks him immediately, doesn't he? He did indeed. And he becomes an implacable opponent of Heath. But he's also a free marketeer, isn't he? He's a free marketeer. So all the kind of corporatist thing, when Heath introduces that, Powell is very, very withering about it.
他确实是。而且，我的意思是，这简直是个笑话。他其实并不是因为希罗多德而出名。他最出名的是他的“血河”演讲，他在演讲中预言移民到英国的结果将是一种种族战争。是的，完全正确。在1968年。所以他被踢出了保守党。所以他立刻解雇了他，不是吗？他确实这么做了。他成为了希思坚定的反对者。但他也是一个自由市场主义者，不是吗？他是一个自由市场主义者。所以所有那种法团主义的东西，当希思引入这些时，鲍威尔对此非常、非常尖刻。
Totally withering. In introducing a compulsory control of wages and prices in contravention of the deepest commitments of this party, has my right honourable friend taken leave of his senses? That's Enoch Powell. That is Enoch Powell. It's like he's in the room. That's not bad, is it? It's not bad.
完全尖刻。“在违反本党最深层承诺的情况下引入强制性的工资和价格管制，我的这位尊贵的议员朋友是疯了吗？”那是伊诺克·鲍威尔。那就是伊诺克·鲍威尔。就像他在房间里一样。那还不错，不是吗？还不错。
I don't think it's as boring as that. Oh, he does. He talks in a low monotone. It is, but it's quite a hypnotic compelling monotone tom i don't think he's actually as brummy as that he's turned into a naughty holder there um yes that's a generic 70s no he talks like that through gritted teeth anyway enoch power has this massive following among kind of some tory grassroots but also people who are not interested in politics, but actually are interested in immigration. They don't like it.
我不觉得有那么无聊。哦，他确实。他用低沉的单调声音说话。确实，但那是一种相当催眠、引人入胜的单调，汤姆。我不觉得他真的像那样有伯明翰口音，他变成了一个顽皮的家伙……嗯，是的，那是70年代通用的……不，他说话总是咬牙切齿。总之，伊诺克·鲍威尔在一些保守党基层中拥有大量的追随者，但也包括那些对政治不感兴趣，但实际上对移民感兴趣的人。他们不喜欢移民。
Enoch was right. The Enoch was right. Yeah. There's a populist side to Powell, I think. Yeah. It's a fascinating character because on the one hand, he is by far one of the most cerebral members of the commons. You know, he's always kind of reading Houseman.
伊诺克是对的。伊诺克是对的。是的。我认为鲍威尔有民粹主义的一面。是的。他是一个迷人的人物，因为一方面，他绝对是下议院中最具头脑的成员之一。你知道，他总是读豪斯曼（Houseman）。
Speaks Urdu, doesn't he? Has taught himself Urdu and is sort of writing learned treatises about Herodotus around the Bible. But on the other hand, a lot of people, they the 23rd of February, the last Sunday of the campaign, at the excitingly glamorous surroundings of the Mecca Dance Hall in the Bullring, Birmingham. So if you remember the Bullring in the 70s,
他会说乌尔都语，不是吗？自学了乌尔都语，并且正在撰写关于希罗多德和圣经的学术论文。但另一方面，很多人，他们在2月23日，竞选活动的最后一个星期天，在伯明翰斗牛场（Bullring）麦加舞厅（Mecca Dance Hall）那令人兴奋的迷人环境中。所以如果你还记得70年代的斗牛场，
probably the worst place on the planet. Well, unless you're Telly Savalas, in which case it's his kind of city. That's right, Telly Savalas did an advert for Birmingham. This whole podcast must be so obscure to so many people listening to it.
可能是地球上最糟糕的地方。嗯，除非你是特利·萨瓦拉斯（Telly Savalas），那样的话，这就是他的城市。没错，特利·萨瓦拉斯为伯明翰拍过广告。这个播客对很多听众来说一定非常晦涩难懂。
Anyway, he goes to the Bullring, which is terrible, this dreadful, brutalist building. He gives this speech and he says, the question is whether Britain will remain a democratic nation with its own parliament or a province in a European super state. So he's the prophet of Brexit, isn't he? He is the prophet of Brexit. And he basically accuses Heath.
总之，他去了斗牛场，那个糟糕的、可怕的野兽派建筑。他发表了演讲，他说：“问题在于英国是会保持为一个拥有自己议会的民主国家，还是成为欧洲超级国家的一个省。”所以他是英国脱欧的先知，不是吗？他是英国脱欧的先知。他基本上指责希思。
Heath has sold out our rights and freedoms to Europe, which is exactly what a lot of people in the Labour Party, like Michael Foote, his friend, his good friend, Michael Foote, are saying, or Tony Benn. And he says, I'm not standing for re-election in this campaign because it's a false campaign. And he says, you should not vote for the Conservatives, for my party. You should vote for the only party that will give you a referendum on Europe,
希思把我们的权利和自由出卖给了欧洲，这正是工党里的许多人，比如迈克尔·富特（Michael Foot），他的好朋友，他的好朋友迈克尔·富特，或者托尼·本（Tony Benn）所说的。他说：“我不会参加这次竞选，因为这是一场虚假的竞选。”他说：“你不应该投票给保守党，也就是我的党。你应该投票给唯一一个会就欧洲问题举行公投的政党，”
which is the Labour Party. And this is, I mean, this totally dominates the headlines for the next few days. There's an extraordinary moment you can see on YouTube where Powell goes to Shipley, I think it is, and there are thousands of people, there are thousands locked out of the hall. Oh, yes. And he's giving a speech again saying, you know, get rid of Heath. Wilson is better than Heath.
那就是工党。我的意思是，这完全主导了接下来几天的头条新闻。在YouTube上可以看到一个非凡的时刻，鲍威尔去了希普利（Shipley），我想是那里，有成千上万的人，有成千上万的人被锁在礼堂外。哦，是的。他又发表了一次演讲，说：“你知道，摆脱希思。威尔逊比希思好。”
And somebody shouted at him, Judas. It's like Bob Dylan. Judas was paid. Judas was paid. I'm making a sacrifice. He doesn't say it like that. He says it much more in an animated way. He said, Judas was paid.
有人对他喊道：“犹大。”这就像鲍勃·迪伦。犹大得到了报酬。犹大得到了报酬。我正在做出牺牲。他不是那样说的。他说的更生动。他说：“犹大得到了报酬。”
Judas was, I am making a sacrifice. And anyway, again, massive headlines, huge sort of, is this going to be a big gift for Wilson? Is he not going to, are the working classes, the Tory working class is going to desert Heath and go for Wilson? Wilson doesn't think so. So Wilson is very despondent while all this is going on. He's very hang dog. His chief policy advisor, Bernard Donoghue, in his diary describes him slumped, tired, sour, scowling, his eyes dead as a fish. But that could be just as readily used as a description of Heath, couldn't it? Well, not this bit. He snarled at Joe about his speeches being too sophisticated.
犹大是，我正在做出牺牲。总之，又是巨大的头条新闻，巨大的那种，这会是给威尔逊的一份大礼吗？他不会吗？工人阶级，保守党的工人阶级会抛弃希思而转向威尔逊吗？威尔逊不这么认为。所以威尔逊在这一切发生时非常沮丧。他非常垂头丧气。他的首席政策顾问伯纳德·多诺霍（Bernard Donoghue）在日记中描述他瘫坐着，疲惫、酸楚、皱着眉头，眼睛像死鱼一样。但这同样可以用来描述希思，不是吗？嗯，不是这一段。他冲着乔咆哮，说他的演讲太复杂了。
He drank brandy heavily. Right. Okay. Not that bit. No, not that bit. But the bit but the other bit but both of them are just shot they're knackered they are depressed wilson i think particularly because he thinks he's going to lose and doesn't he set up a kind of weird thing where he's so confident he's going to lose he he kind of arranges for dummies to go on different cars so that he can't be tracked and he's going to end up in a farmhouse in the middle of the country. It's not quite dumb, but yes, it's basically. We'll get into that in just a sec, Tom.
他喝了大量的白兰地。好吧。不是那一段。不，不是那一段。但是那一段，但是另一段，但是他们两个都完了，他们精疲力竭，他们很沮丧。威尔逊，我想特别是因为他认为他会输，难道他没有设置一种奇怪的事情吗？因为他太确信自己会输，他安排了替身去不同的车上，这样他就不会被追踪，他最终会出现在乡间的一个农舍里。这还不完全是替身，但是的，基本上是。我们稍后会谈到这一点，汤姆。
It's a great story. So the last few days of the campaign, Wilson makes a final broadcast, very anodyne, just says, you know, I mean, it's actually terrible. Trade unionists are people. Employers are people. We can't go on setting water against the air. They're just meaningless babbles.
这是一个很棒的故事。所以竞选的最后几天，威尔逊发表了最后一次广播，非常平淡，只是说，你知道，我的意思是，这实际上很糟糕。工会成员也是人。雇主也是人。我们不能继续让水对抗空气。这些只是毫无意义的胡言乱语。
Centrist gibberish. The rest is politics, basically. Then Heath gives his final broadcast on the Tuesday, and this is absolutely ludicrous. There's footage of Heath on his boat, and the narrator says, an extraordinary man. A private man. A solitary man. Perhaps single-minded
中间派的废话。基本上就是《历史的其余部分》。然后希思在周二发表了他的最后一次广播，这绝对是荒谬的。有希思在船上的镜头，旁白说：“一个非凡的人。一个私下的人。一个孤独的人。也许专注”
sums it up. This is a man the world respects. A man who has done so much and yet a man who has so much left to do so you've got a choice of wilson saying nothing or heath on his boat on a yacht exactly yeah election day thursday all the papers say i mean the headlines are it's heath by five%, a handsome win for Heath. Nobody's actually voted yet. So this is literally counting the ballots before they've been cast. Wilson, as you said, Tom, he thinks he's going to lose. He tells his aides they're staying at this place, the Adelphi Hotel in Liverpool, where
总结了一切。这是一个世界尊重的人。一个做了这么多事，却还有这么多事要做的人。所以你有选择，威尔逊什么都没说，或者希思在游艇上。完全正确，是的。选举日周四，所有的报纸都说，我的意思是头条新闻是，希思领先5%，希思的漂亮胜利。还没有人投票。所以这简直是在选票投出之前就在数票了。威尔逊，正如你所说的，汤姆，他认为他会输。他告诉他的助手们，他们住在利物浦的阿德尔菲酒店（Adelphi Hotel），
he always stays on election night. But actually, he's going to trick the media. He's going to sneak out while everybody's watching the results out of a back door and take a car to another hotel the golden eagle in Kirkby then he will fly to London but the plane will be diverted and he will secretly land in Bedfordshire and he will drive to his house great stuff and when he says all this to his advisors they're like what i mean this i mean yeah also this is britain so these places are often like 30 miles apart it's completely mad yeah and then why is he doing this and they realize this is basically a getaway plan because he thinks he's going to lose and he wants to throw
他选举之夜总是住那里。但实际上，他要欺骗媒体。他要在所有人都在看结果的时候从后门溜走，坐车去另一家酒店，柯克比（Kirkby）的金鹰酒店（Golden Eagle），然后他会飞往伦敦，但飞机会被改道，他会秘密降落在贝德福德郡（Bedfordshire），然后开车回家。很棒的东西。当他把这一切告诉他的顾问时，他们就像，什么？我的意思是，这，我的意思是，是的，这也是英国，所以这些地方通常相距30英里，这完全是疯了。是的，然后他为什么要这样做？他们意识到这基本上是一个逃跑计划，因为他认为他会输，他想把
the press off the sense he doesn't want anyone to track him down when he's lost. And also if he loses, then he will lose the leadership of the Labour Party. That's the end of his political career, Harold Wilson. So it's a gloomy afternoon, foggy, rain is falling. The British people are out voting. But Dominic, how does it turn out? What's the result? Well, all day the tension mounts, Tom. That evening, Wilson goes out on the last tour of his constituency, and it's an extraordinary scene told by his advisor Bernard Donoghue in his diary. He says, they go out, it's foggy, it's miserable, the streets are deserted. He says, we walked in the rain, just the two of us, Harold Wilson and myself,
媒体甩掉。他不想在输了之后被任何人追踪。而且如果他输了，他就会失去工党的领导权。那是他的政治生涯的终结，哈罗德·威尔逊。所以这是一个阴沉的下午，有雾，下着雨。英国人民正在投票。但是多米尼克，结果如何？结果是什么？嗯，整天紧张气氛都在加剧，汤姆。那天晚上，威尔逊进行了选区的最后一次巡视，他的顾问伯纳德·多诺霍在日记中讲述了一个非凡的场景。他说，他们出去了，有雾，很凄惨，街道空无一人。他说：“我们在雨中行走，只有我们两个人，哈罗德·威尔逊和我，”
lonely figures lost in anonymous wet streets. I sensed everybody saw him as a loser, finished, who would soon just be an old backbench MP. Just the mood is so funereal. Yeah. They get back to the hotel. Wilson pours himself a stiff drink and they sit down to watch the results. And at midnight, the results start coming in. And do you know what?
孤独的身影迷失在匿名潮湿的街道上。我感觉到每个人都把他看作一个失败者，完了，很快就会成为一个老后座议员。这种情绪太凄凉了。是的。他们回到酒店。威尔逊给自己倒了一杯烈酒，他们坐下来看结果。午夜时分，结果开始出来了。你知道吗？
It's obviously going to be really really close the Tories are winning all their seats Labour are winning all theirs the toss-up seats there's only a few hundred votes in it of them and it's not until dawn really is broken the next morning Friday morning that the result is. And what has happened is this. Heath has not got his 5%, and he's definitely not got his 10% mandate. The Tories have won 37.9%. Labour have won 37.2%. And the Liberals, led by top bounder Jeremy Thorpe, have won a staggering 19.3% and virtually no seats. And the nationalist parties... So the SNP, Montgomery in Wales.
显然会非常非常接近。保守党赢得了他们所有的席位，工党赢得了他们所有的席位，那些摇摆席位只有几百票的差距。直到第二天早上，周五早上，黎明真正破晓时，结果才出来。发生了什么事是这样的。希思没有得到他的5%，他绝对没有得到他的10%的授权。保守党赢得了37.9%。工党赢得了37.2%。而由顶级骗子杰里米·索普（Jeremy Thorpe）领导的自由党赢得了惊人的19.3%，但几乎没有获得席位。还有民族主义政党……所以苏格兰民族党（SNP），威尔士的蒙哥马利（Montgomery）。
Yes. So basically lots of people have deserted the Tories and Labour for the Liberals and the nationalist parties. And isn't this a kind of seismic moment? Because up until now, basically it had been binary. It was either Labour or Conservative. And from this point on, the kind of duopoly has been broken. The duopoly has been broken. Exactly, exactly that. Now in seats, because of Britain's political system,
是的。所以基本上很多人抛弃了保守党和工党，转而支持自由党和民族主义政党。这难道不是一个地震般的时刻吗？因为到目前为止，基本上是二元的。要么是工党，要么是保守党。从这一点开始，这种双头垄断被打破了。双头垄断被打破了。完全，完全就是这样。现在在席位上，因为英国的政治制度，
the picture is even more complicated. So the Liberals, with their 19%, they've actually got fewer seats than they have percentage points. They have 14 seats and almost a fifth of the vote tremendous that's first place the post is his best because we should explain for non-british listeners that the parliamentary system in britain is pretty brutal yeah for you know not for the large parties exactly if you finish a close second in every village and tower in the country you'll have no mps yeah that's the way it works. That's just life.
情况更加复杂。所以自由党，凭借他们的19%，他们实际上获得的席位比他们的百分比要少。他们有14个席位，几乎占了五分之一的选票，太棒了。那是领先者当选，这是最好的，因为我们应该为非英国听众解释，英国的议会制度相当残酷。是的，对于，你知道，对于大党来说。完全正确。如果你在全国的每个村庄和城镇都以微弱优势获得第二名，你将没有议员。是的，这就是它的运作方式。这就是生活。
It's tough. So Labour have 301 seats. The Tories have 297. So despite having more votes. A higher percentage of the vote, they have fewer seats. And the Liberals 14. And what that means is that Heath can stay in power if he does a deal with the Liberals. So for the next few days, everything is chaotic and in flux.
这很艰难。所以工党有301个席位。保守党有297个。所以尽管有更多的选票。更高的选票百分比，他们拥有的席位更少。自由党有14个。这意味着如果希思与自由党达成协议，他可以继续掌权。所以接下来的几天，一切都是混乱和不稳定的。
Harold Wilson has gone through with his bizarre escape plan. So he's holed up in a farmhouse. He's smuggled himself out of one hotel into another hotel. There was talk of smuggling himself out of the other hotel. And actually, he's gone back to his farm in Buckinghamshire and he's holed up there waiting to see what happens. Heath is clinging on. And one reason he's clinging on is justification is going to be Europe to some degree, Tom, because the Tories and the Liberals are both nominally pro-European parties. And they don't believe in a referendum to get out of the common market.
哈罗德·威尔逊执行了他那奇怪的逃跑计划。所以他躲在一个农舍里。他把自己从一家酒店偷运到另一家酒店。有传言说要把他从另一家酒店偷运出来。实际上，他回到了他在白金汉郡（Buckinghamshire）的农场，躲在那里等待事情的发展。希思在坚持。他坚持的一个理由是欧洲在某种程度上，汤姆，因为保守党和自由党名义上都是亲欧洲的政党。他们不相信通过公投来退出共同市场。
But presumably, it's a measure of the fact that membership of the common market hasn't yet become the salient issue that it, for instance, has been in Britain over the past decade. Because I guess in that situation, if it happened now, the Liberal Democrats, who are the heirs of the Liberals, would definitely go into coalition with a party that was pledged to keep Britain in the EU. Yes, I guess they would. But back then it's not the deal breaker. No, because I think in most people's minds, the issue of the unions, the economy, and indeed the Heath government's performance, they loom much larger.
但大概，这衡量了一个事实，即加入共同市场还没有成为像过去十年在英国那样突出的问题。因为我想在这种情况下，如果现在发生这种情况，作为自由党继承者的自由民主党，肯定会与一个承诺让英国留在欧盟的政党结盟。是的，我想他们会。但当时这不是交易的破坏者。不，因为我认为在大多数人的心目中，工会、经济以及希思政府的表现问题，它们显得重要得多。
So why does Thorpe say that he's not going to go into coalition with Heath? Well, he doesn't straight away. So he also has an elaborate escape plan. People loved elaborate escape plan people loved elaborate escape plans in the 70s he sneaks out of his house in devon in wellies he trudges over some fields then gets a train or a lift to go and talk to heath and london thorpe actually loves the idea of going into coalition personally he would be home secretary tom so that would allow him to preside over his own trial for murder. Excellent. Later on. Yeah.
那么为什么索普说他不会与希思结盟呢？嗯，他没有马上说。所以他也有一个精心设计的逃跑计划。人们喜欢精心设计的逃跑计划，70年代的人喜欢精心设计的逃跑计划。他穿着雨靴从德文郡（Devon）的家中溜出来，他蹒跚地走过一些田野，然后坐火车或搭车去伦敦和希思谈话。索普个人其实很喜欢结盟的想法。汤姆，他会成为内政大臣，所以那将允许他主持他自己的谋杀审判。太棒了。以后。是的。
But it doesn't happen because, for two reasons. One, the sort of high-minded people who inhabit the Liberal Party, they hate Heath. They hate the confrontation. They think, why can't we just get around a table with the unions and give the miners what they want? They're sort of woolly people. They don't like Ted Heath. And also, they really want a reform
但这没有发生，因为有两个原因。第一，居住在自由党里的那种高尚的人，他们讨厌希思。他们讨厌对抗。他们想，为什么我们不能只是和工会围坐在一张桌子旁，给矿工他们想要的？他们是那种糊涂的人。他们不喜欢泰德·希思（Ted Heath）。而且，他们真的想要改革
of the voting system they think that voting system that has penalized them yeah is unfair yeah shockingly which was the price that they demanded for going to coalition with the conservatives in 2010 yes with cameron now the difference is that in 2010 the tories were desperate to get into government and they also thought that they would win the referendum on changing the voting system, which they did. Heath and the Tories then, they don't really want to let the liberals in. They're knackered. They don't want to change the voting system. And they basically, their heart's not really in it. So on the Monday, Thorpe rings Heath and he says, listen, your guys don't really want it. My people really don't want it. It's not going to happen. We're not going to do this deal. And a very, very miserable Heath, who, as we've said, has been colossally unlucky, but has also played his hand, I think it's fair to say, with extraordinary ineptitude, political ineptitude. I mean, he's very well-meaning, Heath, but he's been so insensitive to the political pressures, I think, on other people.
投票制度，他们认为那个惩罚了他们的投票制度，是的，是不公平的。是的，令人震惊的是，这是他们要求在2010年与保守党结盟的价格，是的，与卡梅伦（Cameron）一起。现在不同的是，在2010年，保守党急于进入政府，他们也认为他们会赢得关于改变投票制度的公投，他们确实赢了。希思和当时的保守党，他们真的不想让自由党进来。他们精疲力竭。他们不想改变投票制度。基本上，他们的心并不在其中。所以周一，索普给希思打电话，他说：“听着，你们的人真的不想要它。我的人真的不想要它。这不会发生。我们不会做这笔交易。”而一个非常、非常悲惨的希思，正如我们所说，他非常倒霉，但也玩了他的牌，我认为公平地说，表现得非常无能，政治上的无能。我的意思是，希思很有善意，但他对其他人的政治压力太不敏感了，我想。
And he's been so inflexible. Well, you say by conventional standards, his government had been a total failure. Yeah, I think in lots of ways. So for example, he didn't solve Northern Ireland. He passed all this industrial relations legislation that completely fell apart. He stoked a boom that then went to bust. Yeah, he stoked a boom that entered in total disaster. His heart is so obviously in the right place and where he wants to get Britain to seems so obviously reasonable, more modern, more efficient and all these things. But he just went about it in such a cack-handed way, Tom. So I'm quite torn about Heath.
而且他太不灵活了。嗯，你说按照传统标准，他的政府是一个彻底的失败。是的，我认为在很多方面。例如，他没有解决北爱尔兰问题。他通过了所有这些完全分崩离析的劳资关系立法。他煽动了一场繁荣，然后走向了萧条。是的，他煽动了一场以彻底灾难告终的繁荣。他的心显然在正确的地方，他想把英国带到的地方看起来显然是合理的，更现代、更高效，所有这些事情。但他只是以一种如此笨拙的方式去做，汤姆。所以我对希思感到很纠结。
Right. So you also say if his administration was a failure, it was not an ignoble one. No, he's not an ignoble person. He's definitely not an ignoble person. But maybe if he'd been a little bit more ignoble, he'd have been more successful. If he'd been a little bit more ruthless. Well, Harold Wilson has a very sort of cunning, conspiratorial side to him, as we'll discover next time. And if Heath had had a bit of that, he'd be more successful. Anyway, he goes off to Buckingham Palace with one of his civil servants, Robert Armstrong. He doesn't speak. You know, he's just silent. He's utterly shell-shocked. He's miserable. Wilson, meanwhile, has got a house at Lord North Street
好吧。所以你也说如果他的政府是一个失败，它不是一个卑鄙的失败。不，他不是一个卑鄙的人。他绝对不是一个卑鄙的人。但也许如果他稍微卑鄙一点，他会更成功。如果他稍微无情一点。嗯，哈罗德·威尔逊有非常狡猾、阴谋的一面，正如我们下次会发现的那样。如果希思有那么一点点，他会更成功。总之，他带着他的一名公务员罗伯特·阿姆斯特朗（Robert Armstrong）去了白金汉宫。他不说话。你知道，他只是沉默。他完全被震住了。他很悲惨。与此同时，威尔逊在北街（Lord North Street）有一所房子
in Westminster. He's waiting there with all his aides, and they're all bickering furiously. This is a prelude of what is going to happen. They're all squabbling and fighting. They're all tired and fractious. At seven o'clock that Monday, the 4th of March, he gets the call, would you come to the palace to meet the Queen? So so he goes they all go in a rented daimler his aides are all stuffed into the back of the car he and mary his wife go up to meet the queen the aides sit downstairs they're miserable because the palace heating has been turned off because of the three-day week and then no one's offered them a drink so they're all grumpy and then wilson comes out gets in the car he goes off to downing street when he was a little boy
在威斯敏斯特。他在那里等着他所有的助手，他们都在激烈地争吵。这是将要发生的事情的前奏。他们都在争吵和打架。他们都很累，脾气暴躁。那个周一，3月4日七点钟，他接到了电话，你会来宫殿见女王吗？所以他去了，他们都坐在一辆租来的戴姆勒（Daimler）里，他的助手们都挤在车后座，他和他的妻子玛丽去见女王，助手们坐在楼下，他们很悲惨，因为宫殿的暖气因为三天工作制被关掉了，而且没有人给他们提供饮料，所以他们都很生气，然后威尔逊出来，上了车，他去了唐宁街，当他还是个小男孩的时候
maybe about nine or ten or something i mean he goes off to Downing Street. When he was a little boy, maybe about nine or 10 or something, I mean, he's talking about his love of shorts and he was wearing colossal shorts then. Do you think they were the same ones and they just kind of- Possibly, possibly. Continue to wear them throughout his life. His parents had photographed him, Tom,
也许大约九岁或十岁左右，我的意思是，他在谈论他对比基尼短裤的热爱，他当时穿着巨大的短裤。你认为它们是同一条，他们只是那种——可能，可能。在他的一生中继续穿着它们。他的父母拍过他的照片，汤姆，
as a little boy on the steps of number 10 because you could walk right up to it in those days. And now he gets out of the car and he's such a shabby looking figure you know kind of the shoveled gray crumpled suit yeah tired colossal bags under his eyes and he stands there outside the door the photographer's bulbs are kind of popping and he says uh we've got a job to do we can only do that job as one people. And I'm going right in to start that job now. But what follows, Tom, is more bizarre, comical and Baroque.
作为一个小男孩在10号的台阶上，因为那时候你可以直接走到那里。现在他下了车，他是一个看起来如此破旧的人物，你知道，那种凌乱的灰色皱巴巴的西装，是的，疲惫，眼睛下面有巨大的眼袋，他站在门外，摄影师的闪光灯在闪烁，他说：“呃，我们有一项工作要做，我们只能作为一个民族来完成那项工作。”我现在要进去开始那项工作了。但是接下来发生的事情，汤姆，更加离奇、滑稽和巴洛克。
Yeah. So I've read all your books and I have to say that what is following is the weirdest and most darkly funny chapter in all your books. So if you are a member of the Restless History Club Union, then you can join us for beer and sandwiches in number 10, as Dominic put it yesterday, to hear the absolutely insane story of Harold Olsen and Marcia Williams. Brilliant, brilliant stuff. But if you don't want to do that, that's fine. You can join us on Thursday when we will be continuing the story of Britain in 1974. Thanks so much for listening.
是的。所以我读过你所有的书，我必须说接下来发生的是你所有书中最奇怪、最黑暗、最有趣的一章。所以如果你是《历史的其余部分》俱乐部的成员，那么你可以加入我们，在10号喝啤酒和吃三明治，正如多米尼克昨天所说的那样，去听哈罗德·威尔逊和玛西娅·威廉姆斯（Marcia Williams）那绝对疯狂的故事。精彩，精彩的东西。但如果你不想那样做，那也没关系。你可以在周四加入我们，届时我们将继续讲述1974年英国的故事。非常感谢收听。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews
再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻评论
splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening
一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听
bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奖励剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。